breaking news guys this just ends small
youtuber who looks like other famous
people and gets called everything but
his real name keeps his word i said i
did the earth 2 video a while back and i
said i would do a deep dive i think i
said it 20 likes i would do a deep dive
on the devs and it managed to hit 20
likes took a while uh not not a popular
video
uh
didn't didn't get the quarter million
views that more negative people than me
typically get but we're gonna we're
gonna keep our word and dive into it so
consider supporting and subscribing and
all that stuff or
or don't or just go support people that
don't really need it that's fine too or
actually it's not fine it's sarcastic
why is everyone getting into this
flipping metaverse so much honestly
okay well obviously they just want to
make money they don't really care about
anything other than making money that's
that's the whole goal um but but why
what is the point
uh is it to have fun
is it to
be useful
is it
um
is it so underage kids can can grope
digital people in digital mills and
stuff
that seems to be the actual real point
good job mark zuckerberg really getting
that going for us
all right let's take a moment and just
define an mlm because in my last video i
claimed basically that this was an
mlm because it was all right so off the
top of my head mlm uh basically it's
like a company or a setup that serves no
actual value there's no
real thing it does that's useful to
anybody it's like oh you can look up
look at the earth all right cool you can
already do that there's already google
earth you can go look at it in high
detail for free anytime you want so
this is already done better oh but what
they offer more than that no they don't
they offer less a lot less
sure you can still get images of the
work of it but really what's going on
here is people
are buying in hoping that other people
buy in so that they can make money later
which is exactly what an mlm is you
convince people to buy in so you can
convince other people to buy in so you
can get payoffs for what you bought in
that but there's no actual thing there's
no actual usefulness
right am i wrong correct me if i'm wrong
don't worry i'll be here we'll all be
here
waiting for you guys to figure that out
uh you can maybe explain it as good as
uh way more popular people than me can
like ice poseidon he he knows exactly
what a uh mlm isn't he's pretty good he
scam people for uh what a lot recently
that was some pretty interesting
negative news so
uh it's
the thing is
the masses are really
dumb all right
there's no there's no way getting around
that and normally i'm not the type of
channel that talks about this stuff uh
you might have figured that out but uh
i'm kind of at a loss lately this
channel's not making any money it's
there's no way it's going to support me
unless i jump on the bandwagon and get
really critical of these terrible people
because that's that's basically the
thing that gets views these days no one
cares if i can teach you actual skills
no one cares if i bring actual
usefulness in general that only makes me
like literally 20 30 bucks a month uh
but if i can uh do stuff like this well
i guess this video is probably useful
because i'm at least calling people out
but it's going to occur it's going to
create a little more uh controversy and
stuff and that's that's what makes money
these days controversy right yeah
controversy
just go look at any of the big any of
the big channels that react to stuff and
give controversial takes they're all
doing great probably most of them are
beyond multi-millionaire by now anyway
getting a little off topic all right
well so let's i i think i've summarized
this already you get it
it's an mlm are you still going to buy
in well apparently people still are so
uh
so what do you actually do on this
nothing you still do nothing there's
like little little fake claims and
things like you can get gyms to help get
resources and the resources do nothing
it's it's hilarious it's just a
hilarious system that for some reason is
kind of working i
wow all right so the real question i
want to answer here like as a coder as a
developer myself is this actually
possible is it possible to recreate the
earth and the simple answer is yeah it's
actually quite easy we already have all
the the height maps of the earth so you
can take any little section grab that
height map stick it in a 3d generator
thing
check what terrain it is generate
terrain for whatever that is
plop in some
some generic buildings and sure it's
going to be low detail and and not very
great but actually that's that's really
easy to do
the data is already out there to do it
so why don't they just do it i don't
know
you guys could just do that um if
that's like the really obvious thing to
do okay and then you just make that
editable let people dig let people
give them a little build system
you know most people that are
experienced to game developers could
whip up that system probably pretty
quickly at least at a small scale so why
can't earth 2 do it with a big team and
millions of dollars and all these
companies with millions of dollars why
can't they manage to make anything other
than a grope simulator
but i don't i don't know
because uh i think big companies misuse
and misplace money look at all the
content i've created on this channel
with basically nothing
yeah
scale that up
i could know why we i say well we we
could do amazing things if we had actual
funding
but you know i'm not asking for funding
i don't have a big thing out there that
says hey
you must fund this because you're going
to get
yeah you can you know you can help if
you want i got tears out there
i'm not a not a fan of the whole scam
thing you know as a person that has in
my younger years
been scammed a few times i dislike it so
so much and you know i had half decent
parents they raised me in a way that
that uh
i was trained to be honest you know
things like that i made my mistakes i
learned from them i found out you know
at a young age that stealing a line and
trying to get away with stuff like that
doesn't doesn't really serve you well
but then i get older and i kind of find
out that whoa
most of the people that do this terrible
stuff were actually doing quite well
gratzeis poseidon nice job nice job
yeah you name it go find a terrible
person that you know is terrible like
publicly you know
and uh check out their net worth it's
insane uh being a terrible person is
quite profitable
and uh probably the reason why most of
us won't make it because most people out
there are pretty decent so
we're all just kind of stuck doing
doing the hard labor doing the
the crappy day jobs and getting paid the
minimum meanwhile everyone is scamming
us so
the real answer here is to support the
good people and stop falling for scams
all right that's it's really that simple
but it's often hard to tell scams
because
uh you know these people are often
pretty charming
so i don't know maybe find me charming
you're not i'm not trying to be charming
i'm just spitting it like it is because
i'm actually kind of frustrated and
annoyed so i don't know if you like that
you like that that's fine but uh could
always use more support uh
yeah okay i don't want to make this
about me alright so i did say i would
look at
the developers let's see if we can find
the developers about us
our ideology yeah we already know it's a
let's make ready player one that's not
going to happen i mean
you could do you could literally do what
i said and it would be great you could
you know get the terrain map
and get the terrain type and just
populate that out somewhat randomly it's
not going to be exact copy of the earth
maybe they're too set on it being
perfect and they're trying to make an
exact copy that's it's not possible uh
it's well if it is it's gonna be it's
way too long it's gonna be way too long
to develop that you gotta you gotta
randomize it so uh yeah i guess i'm
doing more work than all your team has
probably done ever just by saying those
few obvious things earth too but
uh you guys have already kind of proven
that you don't really listen to
criticism you just you know for the in
it for the big monies and it for people
buying in and then other people rebuying
in and is there a plan to make an actual
game you can definitely come up with
something with that money heck you throw
me like i don't know a small chunk of
that throw me a 10k and i could generate
you a uh
a playable demo i'm sure based on what i
just said uh whatever i
just hypothesized and obviously it
wouldn't take that much could probably
if you really got creative you could
with a couple other good people you
could probably do in a couple days
for essentially nothing but your time
all the tools already out there all the
data's already free i'm just making a
point all right let's check out the team
the team has been changing a little bit
okay we got shane isaac the founder
do i really need to
i did say a deep dive on there was that
one kid that was uh
the
whatever the known scammer kid i think
they eventually fired him but they did
stick up for him for a while i don't
know it was
yeah
a lot of this just screams they don't
know what they're doing all right these
guys all have linkedin profiles now i
don't i don't support
bashing or harassing anyone obviously
you know i need to say that people
always let me just say that it's common
sense but uh i've learned from many
comments i get in general that most
people don't have common sense well i
take that back a lot of people though
most people actually do the majority of
your comments great
but every once in a while i get like a
comment that i'm just like what
you realize that makes no sense anyway
uh
let's look at shane isaac i guess you
know he's the big dog i gotta join
linkedin
i don't wanna join linkedin right now
okay give me a second
yeah you saw my emails i don't care you
know one of them is the channel one the
other one's like this is my personal one
but also use it for business so it
doesn't really matter all right let's
get signed in here and check out a few
things
all right now
uh here's there's the profile so to be
clear here
there's nothing actually to get out of a
linkedin profile
you can basically
put whatever you want on your linkedin
profile and you can say whatever you
want there's no there's no proof that
any of the things you mention on here
are actually true
um
i i actually deleted my profile once and
i remade it so i kind of lost all my old
stuff but all my old stuff was not even
like hardly real i had like a bunch of
credentials that i didn't even know i
had on here because people were like
they would know me and they would just
want to support me through so they would
say hey this guy's really good at this
and this and this and i wouldn't look at
the person saying that and i'm like
you've never seen me do that you have no
idea if i'm actually good at that so
people just like kind of give you
qualifications
just to try to support you socially but
they don't actually know if you're good
about it that's like the general
experience i've had with linkedin and i
don't know how they're going to correct
that but
so it's more like a
are you socially accepted it has nothing
to do with skill hardly
uh that's that's what linkedin is and
that's what every other social media is
these days and typically why i
personally don't really like them is so
just
you just get a bunch of fake info about
people it's like is this person socially
accepted that's it i don't care i care
if you're interesting i care if you have
good ideas i care if you actually know
what you're talking about i don't care
if you're socially accepted that's uh
i'm not that type of person i know i'm
uh i'm kind of out there as far as that
goes but
i think social media is kind of a big
scam and i'm not a big fan of scams
anyway another side rant there um
what do we even say
oh shane isaacs okay let's
um
last post two months ago
i mean we see his past experience but is
it even real he had a
managing director
of a social media company and then
and then on chief
ceo of r2
okay
skills entrepreneurship programming
business development but mainly
entrepreneurship so
a uh a serial business creator you know
you got to create a lot of businesses
for to get one to stick and this one
didn't necessarily stick but it's
definitely making them a lot of money
because you know the mml mlm factor is
real
and uh and really you know people keep
buying in
why
well defer to some of my previous
statements but
yeah i i don't want to say he's a bad
ceo or anything i don't really know to
be honest
but
uh i don't you know if his main if your
main thing's not programming
you're not a very good programmer and i
don't say that to like bash anybody it's
just that
uh
the reality is programming is incredibly
hard uh you can sure you can do basic
stuff you can follow tutorials you can
code a website you can get a little
things going here and there but if
you're doing like a real big project
as a programmer it needs to be your main
thing because it takes a lot of time to
get things right and just
you know it's it's not an easy thing
that you can say i'm secondary a
programmer
and then you can rely on me as a
programmer you can't really rely on
someone who's secondary skills a
programmer to be a programmer
you might be able to rely on them for
little things like to get little samples
working or little demos working but any
real big reliable project isn't going to
happen from somebody that's not
a main
job programmer i'm kind of worrying that
strangely but you probably get the point
so uh shane isaac will say
okay fine he's the ceo but it's does
does he really have any
um
his stake or
does he really have the ability to
create
the metaverse he maybe with his
entrepreneurial skills has the ability
to hire people that can
but he himself based on him not being
main programmer i think no
all right next guy we got marcostano
acting gameplay concept and design
there is no gameplay in design it's just
like a map so what does this guy do
all right
i don't know once again you know
big grain of salt with uh
this whole
linkedin thing because you know
he already said
there's a lot of things i'm not going to
go into like wolfgang walked he walked
from the team already we're not going to
really address that but apparently
well i guess we will address it slightly
but i don't i don't know i'm not digging
into that specifically but i'll just say
that a lot of people
a lot of the other people i was watching
and listening to they kind of said that
he was one of the big guys that could
maybe actually get this done and he
walked away from the project which maybe
tells you something i don't know you can
you can go into that if you want to all
right
so
i i don't i don't know hardly what to
say
about this guy i don't i don't know
uh really anything about him but he's
got some some experience he's been uh at
earth too for a year and two months all
right it's a somewhat usually it takes
about a year to really get fully
acclimated with your your job
um and it's about the year where you
really hit your stride usually i mean
it's different for every job for
different people different jobs but it
usually takes around a year to get
to get to the point where like you can
truly get stuff done uh
there's just a
lot of learning that needs to be
done before you can start taking charge
and get that seniority and stuff like
that
usually
mathematics and programming tutor air
force officer
and then to
okay
so use some kind of bachelor of applied
silence probably pretty good at math and
then went on to get junior game
designing and
uh yeah i mean
i i don't know he seems like he's still
young in his career i don't want to make
any uh huge assumptions here but
just to be uh
i know to give it like a final review i
don't think that he's going to be able
to create the metaverse
uh so you know but there's more than one
person all right we got a senior
consultant uh florian something uh bone
so he's do you say that bone
get boned all right
no a little off topic all right
enthusiastic people manager and leader
okay so he's probably yeah he's been
here
operations manager for earth too nothing
to do with programming investment
director ceo all right so he's just
making sure it makes money probably huh
all right he's probably doing great
because it seems to be uh continuing and
their company's making money the people
the people that are buying in are they
making money oh maybe if they're really
lucky but uh probably probably not
all right i did promise do this video so
once again i'm delivering please smash
like stuff
please all right um
mark bennett tech and media executive
advisor and investor once again uh
i i don't know here probably just making
sure they're making money you know
there's probably good money and you know
mlms that are successful make way too
much money so there's plenty probably
plenty of money to pay these people lead
technical artist let's see
farron galvin okay i don't know lead
technical artist
um where's the art oh this is the drone
guy so i guess they're trying to like
uh
i don't know
i don't know what's going on here
honestly
yeah he made he made a drone and he
became the technical artist so what's
going on here why can't you bring in a
hype map and have some stuff happen on
it i don't
know i don't know get together fair
i don't know about farron honestly
drones seem like a cool game i don't i
don't want to bash him too much all
right oh oleg kalas something uh cto
ruby rails elixir reactor okay so he's
probably working on their website a lot
with this ruby and rails it's all it's
all website stuff all right so that's
cool
um
what else happened i don't know
is this the guy that left for
a different cryptocurrency startup i
don't know this is a cryptocurrency guy
so he's probably involved in
uh who knows what
i don't think he's gonna be
you know so far so far there's only been
like one actual person who could like
make what
earth 2 is supposed to turn into happen
potentially and that's that's farin uh
everyone else is just like crypto make
sure we make money
um finance investing
so this is this is so far this is not a
game
really at all it's way just based on who
we've seen so far way leaning towards
just making sure they make money which
you know it's not a bad thing you want
your game to make money but
your pro your uh
yeah you know what i'm saying
but i don't see how this works towards
their final goal of ready player one
all right devops architecture
um
he went from webmaster to senior dev to
lead developer
to lead developer to devops architecture
yeah i don't really know it's more of a
sysadmin thing so
it's hard to really say it doesn't sound
like he's involved in gameplay
with that
uh we got this guy he's uh
he's not on linkedin or any of those
sites this tells me that this guy is
really smart this is probably one of the
main guys they need to make sure they
keep if they want things to be
successful because i think not being on
linkedin is really smart if you're a
programmer honestly linkedin is uh
uh
yeah maybe i shouldn't say that but
it linked it's just kind of a waste of
time if you really your main things like
being a good programmer spending any
amount of time on linkedin is just not
going to help you at all
and we got some others that aren't on
there so
this kind of tells me they're making
some potential good choices but it's
also hard to know
for sure uh you know i'm just guessing
there
so
uh yep a couple other guys senior game
developer senior game okay look at this
all the game developers are not on
linkedin you know why because they
probably have actual skills and given
that earth 2 probably has the money to
hire them maybe they're getting
somewhere i don't know maybe maybe not
all right and we got jacob robbie oh
these guys have the same name is it roby
ravi i don't know but they might be
brothers or something huh
not sure
uh but he actually is on here so i guess
he worked on drone
um
the other guy probably worked on drone
too so the whole drone team maybe came
over um all right we got benny paulos
this senior scene feeder
senior financial accountant and he has
deleted his linkedin profile no longer
exist either that or they just have a
bad link
but yeah he was probably getting
harassed or something you know he he's
got that business uh professional look
like he might actually
uh know how to properly scam people um
steve bennett matt box guru
okay
so that's their
yeah they're the whole thing that you
buy tiles with i think he probably just
probably works on that um i mean that
system seems to be working pretty well
overall you can like buy the tiles and
they work pretty good so i would assume
steve bennett's doing pretty good there
and uh putting in some good work
uh security officer duncan
okay
and i'm gonna butcher so many names it's
just zzz
all right
well i like this because uh
security officer
and uh he's got kind of a scary thing
like he's gonna put you to sleep if you
mess with him
all right let's not let's not mess with
him i'm scared don't come at me omar
rahim all right invested in crypto
precede all right just you know all
about that uh
making money with the crypto again once
again we're seeing a lot of that all
right dylan
sayo entrepreneur investor tech
enthusiast vr pioneer
proactive energetic approachable
analytic and goal driven okay
this is strange about
doesn't tell me anything about you other
than you're trying to look that way but
what are you really hmm
all right
uh i don't really know what to say about
this guy yeah honestly maybe you i don't
i don't really don't want to say so
advisory he's an advisor all right we
got mustafa
technical advisor
or technical director
what does it say technical advisor here
but on linkedin he's a technical
director veteran in computer games
technology middleware software
development middleware ooh
no one likes middleware
uh activity great job tim okay okay
technical director mohawk games director
of engineering big huge games senior
development manager at autodesk
uh lead programmer at fire axis games
this is probably the most just technical
the best thing yeah
civilization four
uh
is this all true i don't know i guess
but uh yeah this guy might actually be
highly intelligent capable as far as i
know elizabeth m's community manager all
right uh yeah it's uh
i don't know if there's much to say
about her she probably really has
nothing to do with the company just kind
of you know hired to answer messages and
that sort of thing uh karen edwards
let's uh check this guy out i'm sorry if
i'm butchering names
uh lead quality assurance engineer at
pure gym okay wait
but he's a community manager
all the insurance at pure gym
for six years
yeah he doesn't even mention earth 2 on
his linkedin maybe he's terrified too or
something i don't know maybe it's a
black mark on your
on your resume at this point it's
possible uh owner squeeze creative
theory something
uh hasn't posted lately
don't know really what to say about this
guy bachelor of arts graphic design so
probably just helps okay ui ux design
okay that makes sense but nothing not a
whole lot to do with whether it's
successful or not it probably just works
on the web page maybe works on a little
bit of the game stuff the front end but
you know that there's
they kind of have some game stuff to
show for the to really mean anything so
hard to tell all right let's check out
that in however you say his name game
designer producer
all right
uh
makes indie adventure games and stuff
all right cool
and that's cool and all you know a lot
of these people don't mention earth 2 on
here so maybe they were just short-term
consultants or maybe like when they need
someone to come in they give them a call
and say hey can you work for like a week
or a month i don't really know so it's
hard to tell but it's there's definitely
like
a lot of these people don't seem to
actually like work here full time they
might just be somewhat associated or
being hired as contractors or something
like that it's kind of hard to tell
but their development team is quite
small for what they're doing i mean they
got
they got marx marcostano and they got
these guys without linkedin profiles
very wise um and a couple others but
not a whole lot really
for game
play stuff for what they're trying to do
they definitely need a bigger team like
i can't really speak on how they're
organized within the company because i
have no idea
but uh
yeah i think they need to get their
minimal viable minimum viable product
out if they really want to make any sort
of impact
you know i say that but
they seem to be doing fine with just the
crypto stuff so
all right there i did it
i deep dived on the devs as much as i
could in a quick format so this is just
going to come out as a bonus weekend
video thanks for watching see you guys
next time
go foil out